we have a crap [ __ ] snow crab leg
flatter your crap boob a thank you
alright
bone Appetit again right
are you are you not hungry no I'm hungry
I'm gonna eat some [ __ ] crap and tell
you that shout-out to Jamie Walker
drinking Bud Light smoking cigs and
watching I appreciate you this is a
podcast safe food right question oh you
eat stink lines killing it behind the
board shout out stink lines come get
some boiled peanuts or crab all right
next question yeah yeah that's your guys
box all right Matt cm cubes 44 minutes
ago what has been your favorite car to
drive I have an Audi a8 it was they were
like it's like 1995 rain or something
like that we're gonna have an Audi a8 no
it was like a four-door guy that thing
had a ton of horse powers like 400 and
like 60 or 80 horsepower something
honestly alright I think it was it was
like a four-door this peanut it wasn't
like the sports car figure with the Audi
the sports it was your favorite though
no I'm saying that was a nice nice car
but honestly I I had an Audi Quattro TT
you're the little one mm-hmm like but
people I don't think people think that's
like a cool flashy car or anything but
that was a nice car I loved that little
car yeah I mean that's you know it's
like people have a weird perception of
me or something like I'm doing crazy
stuff and it's just not I think they
equate like getting that much money with
living like a super lavish lifestyle
it's not you know you were just like in
it to be doing it it seems like you mean
Hopkins yeah you're in it listen I need
to see somebody eat some of these
[ __ ] things what do you do seriously
yeah what am i doing I don't eat I never
I don't think I've eaten crab legs but I
break it like that
and I'm supposed to be I mean could you
have picked a [ __ ] so what sucks the
[ __ ] me that come on me man I mean
I'm very selective mean you couldn't got
pizza
I said pizza like three [ __ ] you did
say it yeah you said crab legs and I
said pizza your eyes lit up when he said
crab legs so that's why you ordered it
you got it right there like you got ten
fingers you're supposed to eat real
close to the microphone two crabs only
have like two Matt Cox ASMR ASMR mukbang
Matt Cox Matt are you know had crab legs
before I've had him before but they were
like things you could crack them open
with they had tools and [ __ ] root Kris
Matt fire yeah alright what's the next
question I can't touch my computer
anymore not really a question but Danny
printed these so I'm gonna read it it
says Kevin Love doll four months ago
I need this guy's phone number I only
owe a third of my home's value and I
can't even get a call back from a bank
to refinance it seemed right you got
hard money guy wonder what says DTI is
most DT I mean listen can you get a call
back
I don't know big probably they're
pulling his credit maybe it's credits
bad or something but even then you could
get a hard money loan but hard money
loans [ __ ] it depends on what he
wants to do with the loans you just want
to pull a bunch of cash out and what's
he gonna do I mean is it worth and he
could be he could be saying the wrong
thing like I've had guys come in before
and the mortgage coming they come in and
they owed they were a hundred thousand
on a $250,000 house that's it that's it
that's a no-brainer right you're gonna
do that loan and then when the bank says
well what do you want the hundred
thousand dollars that you're gonna get
out what do you want it for oh I'm gonna
go open quit my job and go open a go
put up a business yeah we're not lending
the money because so you're you had a
stable job which is how you're gonna pay
them back you're now saying I'm gonna
quit my stability and I'm gonna go start
a venture that has a good chance of
failing cuz what is it is it three out
of four businesses fail
I have a question Matt first three years
or something like that if it was should
be good how do you think the mortgage
business is doing I think the banks are
doing with mortgage with mortgages home
mortgages right now during this plague
we're going through oh I'm sure it's
[ __ ] horrible right really I don't
know I I don't how I talked to a banker
today he said it's amazing it's great he
says they're doing all kind of doing
loans more loans than north than they've
ever done that's funny I wonder how
they're doing a lot of new construction
loans too yeah okay maybe he's just
trying to sell me and I don't know what
that I mean listen so how are you
proving these people's income or are
they giving them some kind of exception
where they're saying look you don't have
to prove your DTI because you've been
out a bit out of work for a month and a
half right so you've been out of work
for a month and a half and I'm gonna
give you a loan we don't even know when
you're gonna have another pay stub I'm
asking you for your last two pay stubs
they can't provide them oh I have
unemployment really so you're getting
like a third of what you would be
getting mean I don't even know how that
works maybe they're saying oh no we're
giving you an exemption and we're doing
this and it okay that's possible you
know but I mean I don't do loans by I
can't imagine they're doing great yeah
sure you know a lot about mortgages do
you know anything about Morgan and
Morgan that's that's the lawyers for the
people with mortgages I don't know it
rhymes with mortgage to them Shanee any
questions crabs in crab hit different
I can't scroll through the question
my hand to scroll through these
questions what are these all right
that's dirty no big potato that's a big
potato they're all yours
there's no fork or anything no sorry
unbelievable unbelievable
next question Shane good-looking they're
all kind of like the same they're always
like what's your biggest regret what do
you do is it worth it no is what worth
it no it was 12 years now is the dark
web I didn't use the car all right
here's a different one flash underscore
Gordon since you've made lots of fast
money just working a normal job to you
how to make money seem extra mundane to
you now I don't have a normal job so I
paint paintings and I write and I get
you know I I sell books and I get money
and I got a little bit of money it comes
in every one swallow from royalties and
I don't have a normal job and I'm trying
to UM working on getting a series would
you ever get a like a regular normal job
yeah I would do that I would do that
like just a jiffy lube or something I
mean working at a gym weren't you like I
was you know yeah yeah I was like I
don't know where that something drop
there's a dog in here I mean when I was
in the halfway house I worked in a gym a
little dog
oh brother weirdest [ __ ] this happened I
can't even explain it right now
I can't believe probation here next
question I have a legitimate question
now learned our lesson well they they
corrected our criminal thinking yeah did
it work on you me so far so far so on
the
the American greed series and they go
into the the the art that you would
leave behind no this is like a
legitimate question about like I want to
know like what are some of the things
that inspired you to create the pieces
and like where did that come from like
the sculpture that you left in the
apartment I where did that come from and
like was there any meaning to it or was
it just like a spontaneous act of
creation imitator Chater up I have no
idea this is hot as hell my lips are all
[ __ ] there's water there's bottle of
water out there you need more car I know
I brought the wine then we have a talk
about not getting spicy bull Wow he does
he just doesn't care listen to himself
probably true so I would love to redo
that statue like I've tried to
completely do it twice both times
something has happened like and I ended
up having to ditch this statue or
something summer even so I'd look oh I
know I was actually working on that
statue again when I got arrested in 2006
and the other time was we couldn't fit
in the back of the van but we had like
this little SUV thing and we packed our
stuff and I couldn't get in the back of
the van so I ended up leaving it in the
garage and then they said then when the
guy got found that came in the house he
said that I'd stuck it in the middle of
the living room taunting him it was in
the garage you just didn't have room for
it I just didn't have room for it wasn't
I didn't leave it to thought you as but
whatever but that was to their credit
they were just trying to make the show a
more entertaining yeah sure good but it
was like that the sculpture itself
though like that was just like a
reoccurring thing that you would just be
making I don't know why I've actually
drawn that by the way a few times like I
drew a guy in the same kind of basic
position inside of a box tree on has
that picture I need to get that picture
from 300 probably feels it's his picture
at this point been holding it for awhile
so I don't know it's just a this I don't
know if this agony or just being
tortured or just
just yeah I don't know there probably is
I I what would you say Gila why what
does it look like to you
to me it looked like somebody reaching
for help okay because you know it's like
kind of like in this position they it's
like you know he's more like this he's
more like or is he like I forget but
yeah
it's just the head and the arms that's
what it reminded me of I should redo
that I should go get some chicken wire
yeah you really should probably pretty
cool right somebody would buy this bat
[ __ ] for sure yeah who would buy some of
Matt's art oh yeah let's buy some art
subscribe to the page next question